welcome back everyone this is part two
in our series on analysis methods for
NLP we've come to our first method and
that is probing here's an overview of
how probing works the core idea is that
we're going to use supervised models
those are our probe models to determine
what is latently encoded in the hidden
representations of our Target models the
ones that we actually care about
probing is often applied in the context
of so-called bertology and I think
Tenney at all 2019 is a really
foundational contribution in this space
as I mentioned before I think this was
really eye-opening about the extent to
which Bert is inducing interesting
structure about language from its
training regimes
probing can be a source of valuable
insights I believe but we do need to
proceed with caution and there are
really two cautionary notes here first a
very powerful probe might lead you to
see things that aren't in your Target
Model but rather just stored in your
probe model it is after all a supervised
model that you trained in some way
second and maybe more importantly for
the current unit probes cannot tell us
about whether the information that we
identify has any causal relationship
with the target model's input output
Behavior this is really concerning for
me because what we're looking for from
analysis methods is insights about the
causal mechanisms that guide model
behaviors so if probing falls short on
offering us those causal insights it's
really intrinsically limited as an
analysis method
I'm going to focus for the screencast on
supervised probes to keep things simple
but I will mention unsupervised probes
near the end they don't suffer from the
concern that they're overly powerful but
they do I think still fall short when it
comes to offering causal insights
let's start with a kind of recipe for
probing to be careful about this the
first step is that you state a
hypothesis about an aspect of the target
model's internal structure you could
hypothesize that it stores information
about part of speech or named entities
or dependency parses you name it the
hypothesis space is open
you then need to choose a supervised
task that is a proxy for the internal
structure of interest if you're going to
look for part of speech you need a part
of speech data set and you're going to
be dependent on that data set when it
comes to actually defining the probe
itself
then you identify a place in the model a
set of hidden representations where you
believe the structure will be encoded
and you train a supervised Probe on the
chosen site and then the extent to which
your probe is successful is your
estimate of the degree to which you were
right about the underlying hypothesis
but there are some caveats there
let's first walk through the core method
what I have on the slide now is a kind
of very cartoonish look at a bert-like
model with three layers and you can see
these inputs have come in and we're
going to Target the hidden
representation H to start let's suppose
that's the site that we chose to probe
what we're going to do is fit a small
linear model on that internal
representation using some task labels
the way that actually plays out in
practice is instructive right we're
going to run the Bert model on the
current input and we're going to grab
the vector representation there and use
it to start building a little supervised
learning data set where this is some
vector and this is a task label for our
input example
then we run the burnt model again on a
different sequence we get a different
Vector representation at our Target site
and that also contributes to our
supervised learning data set with a new
task label we do it again for a
different input we get a different
vector and another task label and so
forth and so on and we continue this
process for maybe tens of thousands of
examples whatever we've got available to
us in our probe data set and then we fit
a small linear model on this X Y pair
notice that we have used the Bert model
simply as a kind of engine for grabbing
these Vector representations that we use
for our probe model
and of course I chose a single
representation but more commonly with
Bert we're doing this layer wise you
could decide that the entire layer here
encodes part of speech and then you
would build up a data set consisting of
lists of these vectors with their
Associated lists of labels and train a
part of speech tagging model on that
basis and that would be your probe
the first question that arises for
probing is really pressing are we
probing the Target Model are we simply
learning a new model that is the probe
model right probes in the current sense
are supervised models whose inputs are
frozen parameters of the model we're
probing right we use the Bert model as a
kind of engine for creating these
feature representations that were the
input to a separate modeling process
this is very hard to distinguish from
Simply fitting a supervised model as
usual with some particular choice of
featurization right the site that we
chose based on how Bert did its
calculations
So based on one and two we can we know
that at least some of the information
that we're identifying is likely stored
in the probe model not in the Target
Model
and of course more powerful probes might
find more information in the Target
Model but that's only because they're
storing more information in the probe
parameters they have a greater capacity
to do that
to help address this Hewitt and Liang
introduced a notion of probe selectivity
and this is just going to help us
calibrate so to some extent how much
information was actually in the Target
Model
the first step here is to define a
control task this would be a random task
with the same input output structure as
your target task for example for Word
Sense classification you could just
assign words random fixed senses
for part of speech tagging you could
assign words to random fixed tags maybe
keeping the same tag distribution as
your underlying part of speech data set
or for parsing you could assign edges
randomly using some simple strategies to
give you tree structures that are very
different presumably from the ones in
your gold data set
and then selectivity as a metric for
probes is just the difference between
probe performance on the task and probe
performance on the control task so
you've baked in how well your model can
do on a kind of random task that's the
idea
and Hewitt and Liang offer this kind of
summary picture which essentially shows
that the most reliable probes in terms
of giving you insights will be very
small ones here this is a model with
just two hidden units that gives you
very high selectivity there is likely to
be a very large difference between
performance on your task and the
performance of this control model when
the model is very simple
on the other hand if you have a very
powerful probe model with many
parameters you'll have low selectivity
because that model has such a great
capacity to Simply memorize aspects of
the data set
let's move now to the second concern I
have which is about causal inference and
to build this argument let's use a
simple example
we imagine that we have a small neural
network that takes in three numbers as
inputs and perfectly computes their sum
so when one three five comes in it does
its internal magic and it outputs nine
and we'll presume that it does that
calculation perfectly for all triples of
integers coming in
the question is how does it manage this
feat how does this model work you might
have a hypothesis that it does it in a
kind of compositional way where the
first two inputs X and Y come together
to form an intermediate variable S1 the
third one is kind of copied into an
internal State W and then S1 and W are
modular representations that are added
together to form the output
representation that's a hypothesis about
how this model might work and now the
question is can we use probing to
reliably assess that hypothesis
so let's suppose we have this neural
network and what we decide is that L1
probably computes the input Z
and let's suppose we fit a probe model
it could be a simple identity probe and
the probe says yes L1 always perfectly
encodes the identity of the third input
suppose we continue that we probe L2 and
we find that it always perfectly
computes X Plus y according to our very
simple probe model
that might look like evidence for the
hypothesis that we started with you say
aha it's a bit counter-intuitive because
L1 encode Z and L2 XY so it's kind of
out of order but nonetheless the model
is obeying my hypothesis
but the probes have misled you here is a
look at the full internal structure of
this model this is all the weight
parameters again this model performs our
task perfectly but the point is that L2
has no impact at all on the output
behavior and one way to see that is to
look at the output Vector of Weights L2
is just zeroed out as part of this
computation no causal impact the probe
said it's stored X Plus Y and it might
be doing that in fact it is doing that
but not in a way that tells us about the
input output Behavior
so the probe in that deep way in that
causal way misled us
the final goal post that I set up was do
we have a path to improving models from
the analysis method that we've chosen
here I have a kind of mixed answer there
does seem to be a path from probing to
what you might call multitask training
where I'm training this model to do
addition and in addition I train it so
that this representation here encode Z
and This One encodes X Plus y we can
certainly have such objectives I think
it's an open question whether or not it
actually induces the kind of modularity
that we're interested in
but the really deep concern for me is
just that still here we don't get causal
guarantees we can do the multitask
training but that does not guarantee
that this structure we induced whatever
it's like is actually shaping
performance on The Core task in this
case of adding numbers so we have to
proceed with caution
finally a quick note I mentioned
unsupervised probes there's wonderful
work in this space using a variety of
different methods here are some
references to kind of really formative
entries into that literature again I
think these techniques do not suffer
from the concerns about probe power
because they don't have their own
parameters typically
but they do I think suffer that
limitation about causal inference
so let's wrap up with our scorecard
remember probing can characterize
representations really well we use the
supervised probe for that so that's a
smiley face but probes cannot offer
causal inferences and I put a kind of
thinking Emoji under improved models
because it's unclear to me whether
multitask training is really a viable
General way of moving from probes to
better models